what's going on everybody welcome to
another Python and panda's tutorial
video in this video what we're gonna be
doing is standard deviation along with
since I was just showing you guys how to
apply and we did come across an example
where we needed multiple subplots where
we were plotting say open high low close
and volume where those two things are
kind of a different scale volume versus
the price could be useful to plot on
another pane or another window and
matplotlib this is called the subplot so
I'm gonna show you guys that and then
also we're gonna do standard deviation
which is another pandas kind of built-in
things so with that let's go ahead and
get started so we're not gonna use axes
3d anymore so I'm just gonna delete that
and we'll come down here and delete all
this stuff here and that should be good
now we're gonna go ahead and do is what
we can do is we can say DF and then for
a standard deviation we'll call it STD
and we're gonna say STD equals P deed
rolling underscore STD and then we're
gonna say the first parameter that we
put in here is what are we performing
this on we're gonna perform this on the
closing price then the next parameter is
how large of a rolling STD are we're
going to do and so we're say 25 and then
finally we have this min periods and
we're say that equals 1 so the next
question somebody might ask is can we
apply this minimum periods to the moving
average well let's see so let's go ahead
and copy this and paste that in there
this way we don't have to sacrifice the
first 100 values it'll still show the
moving average for those values so we'll
let that go
and now STD there and that should be it
so first of all let's just see so let's
go ahead and print DF head we'll save
and run it and we come over here you
know wouldn't you know it still gives us
100
moving average now it's actually quite
good because what's gonna do for us is
instead of you know taking you know
three values adding them together and
dividing by 100 it takes the three
values since they're less than less than
100 it will just do that many right so
in this case we would say 3 right or
even 1 it still does the average right
which is not an average at all but
anyway moving right along so we have the
standard deviation was done for us so
now what we're gonna go ahead and do is
we'll come down here and say we want to
plot on multiple axes well the way we
can do this with matplotlib is we just
specify the axes so we're gonna say ax 1
equals PLT dot subplot basically what we
do with Matt pot live is as soon as you
notify it about a plot it's gonna plot
on that new plot that you just notified
it about so this is how we can not only
use pandas kind of intuitive plotting
but also use some of the customization
of Matt plot live and I'll show you what
I mean in a minute so we're say x1
equals clutter so plot we're gonna say
it's a 2 by 1 by 1 and then we'll come
down here and then we're just say DF
close dot plot now normally after doing
s1 you would actually say a s1 dot plot
and then we would say DF close like this
if we were just doing regular matplotlib
stuff but we're going to do dot plot
instead so we can use if some will use
our parameters there we're ready dot
plot instead so we can use pandas
intuitive plotting and then what we can
do those we can then specify a x2 I'm
gonna say x2 does PLT dotsub fly again
it's a 2 by 1 by it's a 2 by 1 and this
will be plot number 2 and then this one
we're going to say DF STD dot plot and
then PLT - oh so now we can plot this
all up maybe I don't see my lettuce okay
so wait for it and here we go we have
our standard deviation down here and
then we have
our actual plot up here now couple
things one we did not have lets show to
two of the things that are wrong here
one we just have the index number down
here it's just a number and then to the
axes aren't tied to each other so if we
zoom in on one doesn't zoom in on the
other one so there's a couple things
that we need to change so first of all
on the definition of AX two we're gonna
say share x equals ax one so it's going
to share the axes with this one and then
also where we have the definition of
right here for parse dates
we're gonna say index underscore call
equals dat capital D you don't forget it
date now when we go to do this we got
rid of that for the three D plotting but
now when we go to plot it we get dates
there Thank You intuitive pandas you're
too kind so now we actually have them
and then also when we zoom in to any
specific spot it zooms in on both charts
so we can see the numbers lined up okay
so now we've got standard deviation and
then we've got the actual plotting and
then also multiple you know subplots and
then now I can show you guys what it
what this headspace and all this stuff
does so wit space we don't have any
width so that's not really gonna do
anything but headspace that will do
stuff so we can close up the difference
make a huge or whatever you know so
anyway so it's gonna include this video
just want to show you guys standard
deviation as well as plotting multiple
plots while still using the intuitive
plotting of pandas so if anybody has
questions your comments for freely than
below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time